I'd like to set your puzzle the puzzle
is about a cat a mouse and as is
traditional in cat and mouse situations
one is chasing the other the mouse is
super quick compared to a cat even
though the cat is pretty quick but in
this case to keep interesting the mouse
is without realizing run into a pond
there's this whiskers and little tail
and if you go anywhere in the pond
because the cat worst mouse it's got to
be small isn't it like I could draw it
big and then you'd be like worst pond
ever compared to the mouse anyway to
scale then here is the cat good enough
No how's that it's gotta have ears all
right
yes it's not bad that's better so for
the sake of the puzzle the cat is gonna
sit on the edge but it can cruise around
the edge waiting for the mouse to leave
the pond that's like stalking the air
exactly now I think it's believable that
even though the mouse could run quicker
than the cat on land in water it's going
to slow down it but it can swim we're
not gonna we'll do the modeling
situation you know Steve some things
like the mouse it's not going to drown
it can swim that assuming the cat
doesn't actually go in the water
although it probably could and swipe it
from the edge all of that stuff let's
just assume it sensibly for puzzle world
and let's assume the cat can run four
times quicker than the mouse can swim in
fact that's the only numerical detail
I'm going to give the cat can walk or
run four times quicker than the mouse
can swim and that's it so the simple
question now is can the mouse escape
[Music]
it's not a Finn sports video without a
computer animation bit of a geogebra
file with some nice brown paper to
represent our pond as ever we've got a
cat who runs around the edge luckily he
looks in the right direction I'm very
proud of that animation I'm very glad
that everyone else is appreciating that
the mouse can go anywhere he likes if he
goes the other side of the cat does
check where he's going but let's assume
he starts at the center and there's a
couple of things to sort out first is
that one tactic the mouse could do is
the obvious one of run away in this case
swim away but you could just say like
why don't you as a mouse just swim away
from the cat and what I mean from that
is like if you imagine a line from the
cat to the mouse wherever that is
imagine that line and the mouse swims in
the opposite direction and I can show
you that happening actually so I'm going
to click this button up here is the away
tactic and the reason I'm showing you is
that it doesn't work then you see the
mouse is following this little arrow
which is moving around depending where
the case but the count is so quick that
you can always kind of get around to
head the mouse off even though it looks
like he was going to make it the cat
camera was real quick and we get these
actually nice pans are turning up which
are typical of these curves that pursuit
they're usually kind of curvy they're
not always easy to model mathematically
and these ones that you know they're
always getting symmetrical but there's a
little bit of randomness you can see the
cat wobbles when he gets in line cuz
he's he's constantly trying to move but
he doesn't need to move because he's
already as close as he can get to the
mouse but it's pretty obvious after
watching this for a few seconds this is
going to repeat even if it's not gonna
be exactly the same path the mouse looks
like he's doomed
so the runaway tactic or swim awake
tactic doesn't work which means if
you've been thinking about that on your
little pause where you were just
thinking about it you should probably
stop thinking about it because it's not
going to get there all right well I
think it's a pretty sensible tactic and
we it'll be a stupid thing not to try it
first and it's difficult to sort out in
on paper with mathematics whether it's
gonna work so the nice thing to do quite
often for mathematicians even physicists
do this sometimes is to model it on a
computer and realized very quickly
doesn't work I'm gonna suggest a hint
now though that I think the mouse can't
escape and therefore it's instructed to
think if this isn't working
how else could he possibly do it and get
away
okay so again if you want to have a
think about it how think about Mouse has
not gone away yet the obvious tactic of
running away or swimming away doesn't
work and one other tactic which a lot of
people tell me with this puzzle that
might be sensible is instead of running
away from the cat maybe you should run
towards the point which is farthest away
from the cat so I think that's obviously
in this case the pond edge point
opposite the cat no no it sounds like
that's the place you want to be if you
can arrange it because the cat's not
anywhere near to eat you of course that
the opposite point tactic so I'm going
to show you what happens if you try a
mouse doing the opposite point tactic
here we go you see the green arrows I'm
heading towards the point opposite the
cat which is chugging away around
because the cat is quick and it keeps
chasing the mouse and this angle is
trying to it's gonna close the angle and
it just means the mouse goes in circles
because he's not moving quick enough
obviously the puzzle will be different
if the mouse was quicker but it wouldn't
be as interesting because the mouse
could just swim through so I just wanted
to point out another sensible tactic to
try swim away from the cat towards the
opposite edge doesn't work either and
this time he just goes around in circles
there are two more tactics I want to
show you neither of which really help
but together they're quite good so let
me introduce some vocab which I've just
made up which will help me refer to
these tactics what I'm going to call the
dash tactic which is swim away but not
away from the cat or towards the
opposite edge but just towards the
nearest edge of the pond
I feel like sensible tactic you're in a
pond they wanna get out you don't swim
the long way so on the screen this looks
like this so I've got a dash tactic and
the moment my mouse is closest to that
point over there it's kind of like the
radius from the point through the mouse
to the edge and if I click on - he just
heads towards the a
now obviously that wasn't very
successful but it depends where the
mouse is to start with right if I put
the mouse on the other side a long way
away from the cat and he's close to the
edge then a dash will get him out that
doesn't solve our problem but it means
there are some places in the pond where
if the mouse can get to I know he can
get out with a dash tactic second tactic
then is not a dash technique this is
circling tactic and this doesn't help
you get out but it does help you get
away so what I mean here is that the
mouse can move in a circle and this
point here is worse for the mouse then
this point despite being the same
distance from the edge so I think this
one's better because in terms of an
angle he's further away from the cat
which means measuring this angle just
drawn a line on here it's a good
indication of whether the mouse is far
away like opposite or close and actually
I think that kind of summarizes the
cat's technique as well the cat will try
and minimize this angle and if the mouse
has got any sense at all we should try
and maximize that angle but it doesn't
always work so here's a circling tactic
if you are near the edge of the pond
it's a problem because there mount the
cat is much quicker
for example the mouse is just circling
but it's clearly moving slower around
the angle than the cat and if the cat
was actually doing something sensible
instead of is going round let's actually
make him pursue he will get to the mouse
and it will stop and then the circling
tactic sump doesn't work anymore because
whatever the mouse does the cat can keep
up but if I get further away from the
edge but I put it over here you can see
that the cat catches up but just not
quite as quick which might give you a
clue that if I'm rightly in the middle
it's pretty obvious that even if the cat
is really close in the angle the mouse
can get away now so the circling tactic
means sometimes I can get away from the
cat in terms of the angle and sometimes
I can't because the cat catches me and
those two tactics maybe I maybe it's
time for another pause with those two
tactics I think
there's a glimpse of a hope those two
tactics the - tactic and the circling
tactic which sorts out whether you can
get the cat opposite you or not and
let's sort them out one at a time so
then the - tactic let's assume the -
tactic we are opposite the cat so if the
cats here the mouse is on this line the
other side of the center but if he is at
the center I don't think he can make it
and maybe you can think about why the
cat has to go around here let's assume
some things which includes this radius
of the pond which I've never told you
I'm going to assume it's one and you can
scale up if you want the distance the
cat has to go round is half of a
circumference so around is 2 pi times
1/2 it's PI meters let's go with meters
for the sake of unit and let's assume
there's some speeds going on let's seem
the cat speed for the sake of any other
argument is 4 meters per second that's a
quick cat and then house is therefore 1
meter per second and that's the only
number we set this up with their cat is
4 times quicker than the mouse can swim
and you can see that if the the mask
from the center will less says 1 is
going to take precisely one second to
get out
but how long does the cat take to get
around well yes this is everyone's like
wow which how do you calculate this I
think the speed equals distance over
time thing is a really basic equation
that we really need to use carefully how
long will it take the cat to get there
time is distance over speed the distance
is pi so it's PI divided by speed which
is 4 is PI by 4 seconds so it's quicker
than a second it's because pi is less
than 4 this is less than one second the
cat is there waiting first thing when
the - tactic is clearly the mouse can't
depth from the center so the obvious
question is where can he desk from and
it's the same calculation right he's got
PI by 4 seconds at most to get out so
because the cat can get to any point on
the circle within ya the farthest away
point is PI by 4 seconds away so
actually he can only get to the edge
when the edge is less than PI by 4 away
because he goes 1 meters per second
we've set these numbers up to be quite
nice but that circle has distance PI by
4 there which means this dis in here is
1 minus PI by 4 and you begin to realize
very quickly that my scale historian is
terrible we need to know roughly where
that line is because outside that line
if I'm opposite the cat I'm home and
dryer just dash for it initially let's
just check you oh you're all estimating
us on the video but one minus PI by 4
0.2 one from Center - tactic it's like
an event horizon bit yes
that's exactly what it is like inside
that you're doomed with your - tactics
out like that if your opposite the cat
you okay so now the question really is
can I get opposite the cat outside that
event horizon so we actually now you
recognize why the circling tactic is
important because that's the one that
concerns whether we can get opposite
attack so let's talk about beer that I
call it the TAC I'm at the cat reversing
things let's talk about these circling
this in some ways is feels harder to
sort out at first cuz like running in
circles feels difficult but
if the cat is running at 4 meters per
second and the mouse is at 1 and
actually what we care about is how
quickly I can get round compared to the
cat going round how big a circle can I
keep up with the cat if it's 4 times
quicker than me I think on moments door
is friends of the obvious that if the
circle is 4 times smaller I'll be doing
the same thing as the cat so actually
this circle I've just gone here if
that's 4 times smaller than the big one
the scale factor of 4 going on the
distance round it is 4 times shorter
than the big one that's how a scale
factors work and so at that point which
is a quarter of the size in which case
that is 3/4 and the distance in there
looking pretty messy thanks to my
repeated drawing of mice but it is a 1/4
on that circle I can keep up with the
cat in terms of angles which means
inside that circle I can outpace it yet
in terms of angles so which means I
think 1/4 otherwise known as 0.25 meters
from the center my circling will work
this point these two numbers and their
comparison is important and deliberately
sort of talking slowly to let the
realization stop in this is a nice
puzzle where the massive Don is is
really lower than GCSE level maths and
yet it wasn't obvious to me at all when
I first started playing with the cat the
mouse but let me show you on the diagram
on the screen so now we've established
that the there are two event horizons if
you like we can put the one here so the
- boundary is this line here in fact
that was the boundary said was 0.21 away
from the center and you can see it's
about right and the circling boundary is
the outer line there so inside that I
can circle okay and outside the -
boundary I can - okay can you see what I
see that there's a little gap in between
which I'm going to officially call the
mouse sweet spot if it can get in there
then not only can it circle to get away
from the cat it can also when it's ready
i opposite the cat it can just peg it
and it should make it which is weird
because just swimming away from the cat
won't make it and just swimming towards
the opposite bank from the cat won't
make it but this tactic according to the
math should make it so I set up Joe
Dubrow which doesn't know about these
boundaries - a tale told the mouse to
get in that sweet spot and then when
it's opposite the cat or close enough
like about hundred 79 degrees or there
abouts peg it and I was really quite
nervous when I'd done the coding to see
if it actually make it because I must as
they should make it and no other tactic
on the model had worked so I'm going to
press play I'm glad Brady that's why you
make these videos so I'm gonna start the
mouse in the center of the pond because
I know that if it's anywhere else I
could still swim to the center and solve
it from there and let's see what happens
I'm gonna click on escape tactic and
what I hope the program will tell it to
do it it will swim out until it gets
into that sweet spot which is that small
little region and then it was circle
until they recognizes this opposite the
cat you'll see the angle go up to about
180 or within some tolerance and then
you'll pick it and I've no idea where
we'll end up to pick it but if it gets
to the edge the exciting payoff will be
a bit of red tech saying the mouse has
escaped that's what I'm hoping for
ready I'm really
found the sweet spot very quickly he's
only just inside the sweet spot you see
the angle is increasing but it's not
quickly increasing come on Mouse it's
made it I agree that would be a tense
moment for the mock-ups but if I assume
as I did right in the beginning when the
mouse is much quicker on land and the
cat I could just imagine a game and
their cats like ah but I think the math
tells me that wherever the mouse starts
whatever the cats doing if it's four
times quicker than the master swim it
can escape so how fast does the cat need
to be for the mouse to never escape
Brady I like your style you're doing
what all mathematicians want to do in
their heart of hearts actually most
humans that you're generalizing right
the four is critically chosen so that
that point to one and 0.25 are really
close together and then the right way
round if they're the other way around
you you can only - from a point where
you can't a circle whereas we had a
sweet spot and actually I've got a
slider on Joe Dubrow so I can change the
ratio of the speeds and you can see
whether the sweet spot increases or
decreases so since you asked let's let's
move the mouse back to the center let me
turn these too often that is the region
that I called the sweet spot the
critical region is maybe a more
technical name for these sort of things
at the moment the ratio is four if I
change that to four point one can you
see the sweet spots gone really quite
small which means if the cat is four
point two times quick it is all over
somewhere between four point one or four
point two looks like is the end of the
story if I go the other way you can see
the sweet spot is really big this is not
a surprising the cats lower the mouse
has got a better chance in fact there
gets to a point where if the mouse is
not quick enough even at three point two
in fact if I go between three point one
and three point two you can see that
something there's it's all sweet spot in
the middle and 3.1 at 3.2 do bracket a
famous number which I'm sure people have
heard of and I've used it's called pi it
says to do with actually the speed
compared with pi here if it's less than
pi it's all sweet for the mouse and in
fact
it can dash from anywhere and get out so
there's a really tiny area and for is
this lovely chosen whoever came up with
this puzzle I haven't managed to track
down who originally came up this puzzle
seems to have been around a long time
but I hadn't heard it until a couple of
years ago when someone told me about
this puzzle we were sitting in a
bunkhouse in the leg district around
fire and he said I got a puzzle for you
and just told me about the cabin the
mouse and I don't know as bit arrogant
perhaps I was like this is gonna be a
simple puzzle completely flummoxed me
for a week I was thinking about it
driving back from the Lake District and
when I solved it I was really pleased
that it wasn't that I didn't know the
maths it's just that it was a nice
puzzle and they've chosen the for really
well because any other number much
bigger than for much more than before
and either it's too easy for the master
escape or it just always gets caught so
that's the cat-and-mouse puzzle a bit of
play and a bit of pond so if you like
challenging problems like the one we've
just shown you but maybe you want
slightly better pictures than Ben's
Mouse here brilliant might be the place
for you brilliant have sponsored today's
episode and they have really cool daily
challenges like these have a look at
them this one about hitting a bowl
around a corner appeals to my brain
obviously I'm gonna click on this one
it's pretty interesting stuff here and
look at that that is quite a shot but
how could it be played to check all this
stuff out go to brilliant org slash
numberphile that's not only going to
introduce you to the brilliance of
brilliant but it also sets you up for
20% of their premium subscription
premium means you get access to not just
the free stuff that's on the site but
all the archives all the puzzles all the
courses all the daily challenges that
address again brilliant org slash
numberphile use the slash numberphile so
they know you came from here and check
them out
[Music]